the Cloverfield paradox is already on
Netflix it was originally called God
particle and then it was announced it
would be Cloverfield 3 after the first
film in 10 Cloverfield Lane and now all
of a sudden it's on Netflix they just
announced it on Superbowl Sunday
everyone gets excited this guy included
the first Cloverfield is one of my
favorite monster movies and I really
liked the second as well I like how this
franchise is different each entry is
unique and it keeps it fresh this film
has been marketed as the one that will
tie the previous two together
and set up more possibilities for a
Cloverfield universe that will change
the way we look at franchises and in
some ways this film absolutely does that
and in other ways it does some other
things that we're going to talk about
now I have a lot of things I want to say
I've thought quite a bit about this I
was full on board
Fox Mulder sitting at my desk playing
with pencils trying to figure out how to
approach this review and eventually I
turned into Charlie Day from it's sunny
trying to connect all the dots and make
all the charts and eventually I just
said to myself screw it just say what
you want to say and try to be as
analytical as possible without being too
confusing and to do that I have to talk
about spoilers this movies on Netflix
you can go watch it right now more than
likely if you're a fan of the first two
you probably already have this film
takes place on a space station called
Cloverfield we have astronauts who are
out in space trying to figure out how
they can harness a new form of energy
for the planet because energy is
depleting and it's running out extremely
fast our main character in the film has
a very tragic past her children were
killed when she accidentally left an
energy cell on in the house and it
caught fire and her husband is back on
earth when an explosion happens he
rescues a young girl who was caught in
some rubble and he sees shadows of a
giant monster running around and when
he's on the phone towards the end of the
movie he seems to suggest that there are
monsters plural now if you saw the first
film you know that there was a giant
Cloverfield monster as well as little
tiny monsters that kind of sprouted off
of that monster so that could be what
he's referring to or this could entirely
be a different dimension from the first
film or the second there are so many
theories that you could make up
to support this film or to knock it down
and that's one of my biggest issues with
it it's very unclear
I'm all for ambiguity I like films that
require introspection that make you want
to think about the movie that make you
want to analyze it and that aren't easy
to answer the problem is despite the
fact that the Cloverfield paradox is all
of those things it's also a very silly
and trite film that has a lot of very
unnecessary storytelling elements
shoehorned in news footage with an
author talking about his book and his
fears of the possibilities of two
different dimensions colliding and
ending that at first glance really does
not make sense when you compare it to
the ending of the first Cloverfield the
ship comes down out of space through the
clouds and then the Cloverfield monster
just bursts into view this Cloverfield
monster is even taller than the clouds
which could mean either a this is an
alternate universe or dimension and this
dimensions Cloverfield monsters are just
that big or B this is a fully developed
Cloverfield monster whereas the one from
the 2008 Cloverfield was an infant not
even tall enough to reach above New
York's biggest skyscrapers so branching
off that there's a lot of things I want
to talk about and this is also gonna
spoil the first Cloverfield and maybe
we'll get into some spoilers for 10
Cloverfield Lane as well so at the end
of the first one if you look really
closely this was a big thing in 2008 I
was all over the forums for this movie
you can see a little satellite or piece
of debris but it was sort of eventually
revealed to be a satellite fall out of
the sky into an ocean the background of
their carnival footage and that was
supposed to be what awoke the
Cloverfield monster so at the end of
Cloverfield paradox it's like they're
showing that happen except the
Cloverfield monster did not make
landfall in 2008 Cloverfield until far
after that event he's also not taller
than the fucking clouds so that's
something to think about and in 10
Cloverfield Lane at the end of that film
you realize that there's an
alien invasion going on there's already
aliens on earth and there's a gigantic
mothership at the end when she's driving
towards the city so for a lot of people
that was very confusing the problem that
I am having with these 3 Cloverfield
movies is the timeline it's all becoming
muddled it's difficult to understand
what happens and when it happens and who
it happens to and since this film deals
with different dimensions colliding
which is what happens in space and
there's a shift that occurs you begin to
wonder well okay so if this film takes
place in this dimension does the 2008
Cloverfield take place in an earlier or
different one is this just another
dimension that's now being created with
another Cloverfield monster what about
10 Cloverfield Lane is that another
dimension do these all just take place
in different times and different zones
of universes and existence so halfway
through the movie I thought to myself
ooh this is really clever if they're
saying that the earth that paradox
starts on is a different earth and
halfway through when they get thrown to
another dimension I was thinking oh shit
this is the 2008 Cloverfield dimension
that they're gonna go back to I was like
oh this is awesome but then they would
cut back to her husband on earth in the
original earth they set up and he has
what seems to be a modern-day smartphone
apparently Cloverfield monsters there
this is why this is why I think I am
having so many problems with this film
as a simple space thriller this film is
filled with respectable performances and
it has some intense direction some good
production design very nice special
effects and as a space thriller it works
well enough but as a film that tries to
traverse and connect the Cloverfield
universe my brain is exploding and not
in a good way I like analyzing films and
this film has kind of it's made it a
little hard and again I got to reiterate
you could really defend this movie
because there are so many theories you
could create as a
hence for the things I'm saying the
problem is is that they would just be
theories the movie doesn't really seem
to have any concrete answers for what
it's trying to set up and the problem is
if you are a huge fan of the Cloverfield
movies like myself and you've watched
them and tried to connect them this
movie was supposed to bridge the gap in
fact Netflix on their Facebook to market
the trailer they were like 10 years ago
something happened now find out why this
doesn't really make anything any more
clear and not that it needed to be the
first Cloverfield was a great contained
monster movie Matt Reeves did a great
job at that movie and it was a lot of
fun the second film was also really good
and you could take the ending or leave
it but the film itself is a great
contain thriller this movie in trying to
bridge the gap between the two just
creates more questions than it really
needed to while also having a lot of
really lazy storytelling aspects along
the way like unnecessary exposition and
jokes that sometimes worked but also
felt kind of forced the things this
movie does really well beyond the
aesthetics beyond the performances is it
does have a breakneck pace of fun
adventurous thrills in space and I have
a soft spot for isolated films in space
but that breakneck pace is a result of
feeling like everything has been crammed
into a very short runtime when this film
easily could have been 2 hours or more
to try to tell a more cohesive story so
in the end my favorite thing about this
movie isn't necessarily the film itself
it's actually how it was marketed and
the way we're now getting information
like this and how surprising that was
which you know I would have liked to
have enjoyed the film a lot more than
the marketing I'm gonna give the
Cloverfield paradox a seed
it's a respectably made film if you
don't really care about the Cloverfield
movies you can watch this as a simple
space adventure and probably enjoy that
aspect of it but if you really want to
think it's just gonna make it more
muddled which is kind of maddening
because this film was supposed to help
provide a little more answers and some
more cohesion but in the end it's just
created so many possibilities that it's
tough to actually harness one and be
like that's what it is
because now it's just anything which may
have been the goal because now they
could make a Cloverfield movie out of
anything they have so many possibilities
and so many different universes and
event and dimensions that they could do
anything now which I guess might have
been what they were trying to do but
that's disappointing for me a long time
Cloverfield fan also stay tuned later
this month I'll have my review for the
good the bad and the ugly published I'm
looking forward to doing that guys are
the best and as always if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]